字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive
字幕志愿者 李宗盛他差點找不到網頁有聽到聲音喔 我們要來今天的直播了
最近這個大盤很瘋狂齁
那我在這個禮拜
禮拜天的課呢 就講了齁
這個大盤呢 非常的瘋狂
所以呢 現在這個位置呢
現在這個位置齁
現在在這個位置你也不用想太多啦
你想太多每天怕崩盤什麼的
你就沒辦法賺到這個瘋狂的行情
因為現在的行情實在是太瘋狂了
你只要蛋白有點覺得會崩盤的話
你可能在這段行情你可能就會賺不到
面對瘋子的行情呢 我們只能比他更瘋
然後呢 就做點避險嘛
做點避險
那我們的處置策略呢
他本來就是多空都有得做
那我們大部分是教如何做多啦
因為做空大部分還是危險性比較高
但是你假如真的想要避點險的話
其實處置裡面呢 也有一些一日避險的東西
一日避險
那各位可以做一日避險啦
那另外呢 你假如不想做一日避險的話
你也可以做
例如說有些隔日沖可以空
那或者你覺得今天行情不大好的話
像我每次啦
我只要
我只要覺得行情不大對勁
通常5月避險就會找981月避險
因為它的量最大
量很大
所以盤中你要做避險都很容易
那我這個做避險呢
那币點顯呢,我都會看全方位監控
全方位監控啦
像我今天呢,我就有在盤中呢
一開盤,幣點顯
那幣點顯就看全方位監控呢
假如它很快速的全部都翻綠的話
就是全方位監控這邊有很多東西都翻綠的話
都翻綠的話,各位看一下
這開盤沒多久,大概在這個位置啊
這邊9點06分
一開盤還好
到了9點多就發現怎麼樣
就發現 欸 這邊一開始有很多都變成綠色
創低了很多啦
創低很多 所以就覺得今天的盤式呢不大好所以呢 我會利用這個全方位來做避險那我也會去找一些這個隔日沖的做短空
做短空
那當然空呢會挑比較安全的位置
所以
盤中呢我們是靠
盤中靠短空來避險
因為大部分的殺盤都是殺在盤中
那個跳空開低的機率比較低
比較低啦大部分都是跳空開高
台股呢一向都這樣
台股呢都一向容易跳空開高
所以呢我們都這個
每次跳空開低的時候
這個每次
跳空開高的時候就看有沒有出現綠色的
再講
跳空開高呢就看有沒有出現綠色的
假如有出現綠色的話就會先空981的避險
我今天避險呢有幾檔
首先我今天避嫌有找群創
群創蠻好玩的
群創盤中有先
他有這一段
這一段好像有進入緩挫
真的有沒有進入緩挫不知道
但我知道這一段有緩挫
所以呢這邊我有空到
我有空到一個不錯
看我姐有沒有幫我截圖
啊他今天沒截圖啦
因為他今天在我身邊
小編今天在我身邊
截到這個圖 我有空在這個位置
空在這個位置 後面又往下殺
那群創是因為他殺了我才做
那群創前兩天我還做多
前兩天我還做多 我有去掛盤後的多單
那這個怎麼掛 為什麼
怎麼掛跟為什麼
我有跟那個
我們在
我們在那個
周日的課程有講到
群創呢 我有賺到他這兩根漲停
我是在第三根漲停的
我還沒開始講就叫我不要講太多處置神器
我們今天就是要講處置神器的
這個群創我來弄一下我的直播一下
這邊
直播在這邊
我要看一下各位的留言
喔這個呃我在禮拜天的時候有講說為什麼去買群創呢其實有買一些股票那他的理由呢 在禮拜天的時候有說到
那禮拜天是屬於
這個處置的陪跑課程其中一個
我們禮拜天有開了一個兩個
大概兩個半小時的課程
就是有買處置神器的人
就会当天就跟他们讲一下
我在这两个月做的状况
这两个月做的状况
那这两个月做的状况呢
做的...
这两个月做的还不错啦
还不错喔
待会给各位看我这两个月做的状况
好
那一开始呢 请各位加一下
现在浪子回头
强势全面亮灯
全面亮灯
現在 全面亮燈我們來看一下這一段
這一段
等我一下
呃 我 我先登錄一下
我先登錄我的FB一下
啊?完蛋了
我按鍵壞掉了
好,等一下
我先...
先等我一下
這個我們再
看一下
好
等一下,先讓給各位看一下我的
這裡喔
好 都好了
我在兩天前
不是兩天前
應該在上禮拜
上禮拜去節目講了
這幾檔股票
那這邊呢
這邊的漲停裡面呢
有五支是跟處置有關的
有兩個沒有關係
一個是真頂
真頂一個是錦碩
真頂跟錦碩跟處置沒關係
也有介紹這兩檔
那其中這五檔
建策、月城、中探針、紅藤跟台藥
那這個呢都跟處置呢有蠻大的關係
那我在上禮拜
禮拜四呢去節目上面講
然後呢
這邊剛好是
這邊啊
這邊
這有人講說
你這個很簡單
這個就列治選股就好了
沒有啦 我們在當天是有講到的
所以呢都有
都有畫面為證
這個 見側 景碩 台藥 針頂 中探針 紅藤 月城
那這幾個齁
那你看 月城 月城太猛了
講完之後呢 各位你知道他的長相嗎
長相長這樣
這個月城的長相 這裡
講完之後 抱抱抱抱
這個禮拜
禮拜四講嘛
上禮拜四 禮拜四在這邊講
然後禮拜五漲停 禮拜一漲停 禮拜二又漲停
然後呢 這幾個
還有像台藥啊 各位看
禮拜四講
禮拜五 禮拜一
然後
建設也是禮拜四講
禮拜四講
這裡
然後 禮拜四在這邊啦 禮拜四在這邊
禮拜五
禮拜五又漲停
欸?不是禮拜幾講
我想想
有點忘記我禮拜幾講
我看一下我哪天去錄影
我看一下
喔 看圖片是啥
好 我們來看一下這個圖片
等一下
這個圖片 這裡
喔 5月20號
5月21號 應該是5月21號的晚上貼的
那這是5月22號 禮拜五禮拜五貼的文所以這個5月21號長這樣繳完之後 隔天還是漲停
雖然前天是大漲了 隔天還是漲停
所以這幾個呢 它是跟處置有關係的
而且這幾個都是有浪子回頭過的股票
有浪子回頭過的股票
所以浪子回頭去到這很好用啦
所以我們這一次呢
先請各位加一下這幾個QR Code
這邊有Tag1粉絲團Lite,觀光社團Youtube跟IG
然後這個觀光社團教育知識Youtube教學影片
IG呢偶爾會有教學點位
當充點位
那這個九折優惠券
這PP九折優惠券
各位呢可以用一下
然後我們這個
全正巧克的討論群
這個歡迎各位先加
這邊有四個八
4個8 喔 4個8會
會那個
喔 這個
各位先加一下 4個8 我看一下下幾個人加
先加一下 4個8
目前的人數呢 我看一下
喔 看到了
5395 喔 現在5395啦
待會我們再看那個人數會增加多少
因為他們現在是
把那個進出的通知給關掉
所以我們只會從數字看得出來
你看不出來誰進來
這邊會實戰復盤
資訊分享還有解惑都在這邊
那近期的儲置真的蠻好做的
儲置我常常用康爾這個戶頭做
康爾這個戶頭目前
4月到5月儲置是賺了7000
前一天在
上課的時候就有跟學人提的
那時候是5000多
說再過這兩天應該會到7000
因為還有一些以實現損益
在這兩天完成
這兩天實現了
但是我現在的未實現損益
目前為止好像沒有什麼
比較少那個大型的
還剩一兩檔
沒有像之前那個檔數非常多
檔數非常多
那這邊呢 他的交易的邏輯
其實就是我們用浪子回頭去做啦
浪子回頭去做 他的勝率是非常高
非常高 非常高
所以 這個我們講 這個你在市場上很少會找到有人會把賺錢的方法
這樣子分享出來
因為賺錢方法分享出來
一定會影響到自己的權益
第一個就是
它會影響到自己買的點位會變差
那賣的點位也會變差
因為買的時候大家都愛買
賣的時候大家都愛賣
買的點位大家都愛買
大家都愛賣
那所以大家不喜欢分享那个好用的教学
好用的那个交易的招式
那我们在这边呢真的是分享好用的交易的招式
那这边这个就是用
处置神器做的啦
用处置神器做的
那这个处置神器呢
这个很好用
那处置神器做之前呢
你可以先用筹码K线
可以先用筹码K线
来看一下个股的筹码状况
看个股筹码状况
從來可以見得好 因為我們在前幾天
上禮拜有跟各位講嘛
說這個可成啊
可成呢 它的股價進值比好像來到0.75
來到0.75你不用太擔心啦
因為
按照可成 它的
個性齁 就是
來到0.75 它大概就會想要10支庫藏股了
大概就想要10支庫藏股了
所以呢
這個 在這位置我就大買
然後呢 在
在上禮拜的時候
居然讓我買到了一個超級無敵好的價差單
在這邊跟各位分享一下
這裡喔
來 我上禮拜這裡
登登登
各位看一下
好 有沒有看到
上禮拜呢 我就要買到可乘-0.51啊
有沒有
-0.51 漂亮嘛
這個-0.51 我就買一堆可乘
那我買一堆可塵
那買到這價差單什麼意思呢
買到這價差單呢
我就是變成買這個月的多單
然後上個月的空單
我空單就給他結算
上個月空單結算
大概在這個位置
上個月空單結算在185附近
185附近
結算在這個位置附近
等一下我吃個火糖
覺得聲音有點加啪的
我結算在這裡
這幾天 可成也漲起來了
可成這種股票 他就試了存股我們存了六年了存了六年 股價在這裡混沒有看過這麼混的股票了
但是因為
他的股價就一直在那邊震盪
所以存股是還蠻適合的
存股就是波動比較小一點
好啦 可能是這樣
上禮拜有做到他的
做到他的轉倉單
那可能呢我們會
這個從抽馬K事實上有很多資訊可以看
齁 抽馬K有很多資訊可以看
大家可以多利用抽馬K
那不只可成
今天的美率也稍微發動了
美率已經到這個九十幾塊
稍微發動
不過抽馬是抽了點
齁 抽馬是抽了點
那除了這以外齁
這個
這個抽馬K呢 抽馬K蠻好用的
各位你可以從籌碼可以找到一些
找到一些這個
厲害的分點
厲害的分點 例如說像
舉例講
我們在之前講的大力光嘛
大力光有厲害的分點叫三多哥
唷 今天又繼續買
三多哥繼續買
所以大力光只要有機會回檔
都是讓各位上車的
再講一次
大力光有機會回檔
都是讓各位上車的 因為
三多哥狂買
三多哥狂買大力光啊
所以這種
有機會回來
都是不錯買一點
都不錯買一點
這些呢
分點你可以從
這個從籌碼K線來看
好
你購買處置神器
要先買籌碼K
買籌碼K比較好
因為籌碼K呢
可以讓你看到一些籌碼狀況
那儲置神器呢它有一般的
一般的籌碼狀況
就是你會看到主力的買賣超狀況
但詳細分點看不到
那儲置神器很好用啊
我們來看一下
這個儲置神器
各位來看一下今天儲置神器的狀況
那儲置神器我們怎麼用呢
我們就會看一下
它的這個第一個首先來看儲置日報
這一股票呢
你明天最好避開一些
哇 這邊有金彩科
金彩科已經有
已經有這個大幅的
之前有大幅的生貿轉讓嘛
哇 新唐要被關了
新唐被關 假如有機會回來的話
應該也會有不錯的賣點
然後線商店要繼續被關
因為線商店實在長太多了
哇 合金
合金剛出關又要被關
剛出關又要被關
好 那這幾個
這個假如有
一般來講 假如有20分鐘的話
各位呢 最好是避開
再講一次喔 有20分鐘最好避開
就是你不要去碰它
不是叫你空啦 叫你不要去碰它
不要去買20分鐘的股票
那這些 我們也有網頁版
網頁版在這邊
那網頁版呢 你必須要買主制神器呢 你才進得來
因為它進來之前呢 它會先
先叫你輸入帳號
所以各位呢 你用手機版的
這個有不方便看的時候你可以用網頁版
那網頁版呢
盤中呢他就讓你看一下
他的量價的門檻
在哪裡
啊假如是動的話
舉例來說啊假如像這個金彩哥
這個閉關喔
這個應該是明天啦
看明天狀況
明天假如超過這個量呢
他就會出現閉關
再講一次喔
假如明天超過這個量他就會寫閉關
那我們就知道說這金彩哥閉關
金彩哥被關了
我大概是這樣看
那所以這個
各位這些股票呢
假如有被聽牌的
明天記得要注意一下
你要注意一下它的條件
那有被聽牌的記得避開
記得避開啊
我們在這個在上禮拜呢
我們在
這邊
我先
先給各位看一下那個臉書
上禮拜我就發了一篇文
結果呢 有人就去上面抗議
我找一下
我找一下能不能找得到
看一下
就是
就在我
我找一下
在這篇文章
對
拉下來給各位看在這裡喔這裡有有人就說這裡啊
上上次在理財單秀說建設
隔天朋友進場一路套到上桌子
這裡啊
他說
我在這裡說
說建設 我在這邊桌
然後呢 他進場
然後就開始
他進場我不曉得他買在哪個位置
那隔天是有開高嗎
那開高就一路套
然後就怪我 都是我害的
我說你好拜託欸
我們在這邊講對不對
然後你在這一天你無論如何
任何一個 除非你追漲停
那通常散物不會追漲停
無論任何一個時間點買
這邊都會賺錢
然後重點在這一天怎麼樣
這一天我們還有特別講喔
這天還有特別講說
因為在這一天呢
那電車呢 它又會被關
它有一個被關的條件
有一個被關條件
所以呢 只要它被關
我們就會怎麼樣
我們就會先賣掉
先賣掉
那這種被關的呢
我們不只會
假如那個PV上面有人問
我們就會講
不只這個學員問會講
我們甚至呢
我們已經做了什麼樣
我們做了網 那個做了APP
讓你可以去查
那你都知道說我們這些教學的策略了
難道我在這邊錄影完
那講完之後 我們還要講說
欸 未來 各位記得
明天 因為我哪知道隔天會漲停
那隔天會漲停
它就會 也會影響到隔天聽牌的條件嘛
他那個聽牌條件是每天在變動的
所以我沒辦法一下子就預言到
再隔天 再隔隔天
他的聽牌條件怎麼樣
也沒辦法把你的這個進出場的
那個SOPX講得很清楚
因為我根本不曉得股票會漲到哪裡嘛
那假設建設他在這一天是大漲的話
他就不會被關
不會被關就不用賣掉嘛
所以有些細節其實
你必須要自己去研究
你不是聽了別人講之後那你買你有買 賺錢賺錢都自己的事然后只要一赔都别害了都别害了那这个逻辑呢
其实我们都有讲清楚
那我们都是提早讲 提早做
只是我没办法每天去电视上面跟你讲啊
我不可能每天去理财团就录影嘛
假如每天去的话我就会讲说
建设明天要注意啊
明天呢 他有被關的條件
假如我去錄的話
我跟各位講
我看一下
這禮拜呢
我是明天錄影
我明天錄影
這禮拜我明天錄影
那明天錄影呢
有什麼條件比較要注意的
我會跟你講
我在電商跟你講
那假如那個
想每天看到我的
你就PP上面看
PP每天都會看到我
甚至你可以問問題
問說這個股票悖關條件怎麼樣
這你都可以問嘛
那這種悖關條件呢
我們也會教你 你怎麼用處置神器看
處置神器也可以看
也可以看
我們是
我們是不只教你方法
不只教你方法
還設計了工具給你
我只差不能當一個投稿老師
然後每天跟你講說
幾塊買進幾塊賣出而已
因為我假如當投稿老師
我跟各位講說
我當投稿老師是國家的損失
國家的損失喔
為什麼國家的損失
欸
我每個月繳稅就幾百萬了
每個月繳稅幾百萬
我每年的交證交稅都上千萬
我每年交那麼多證交稅
我一當投稿老師
我就不用交這些政策稅
我就沒辦法打單了嘛
對不對 我每天打那麼多單
我每天有一堆交易賺錢的方法
那我們是實際做
那覺得好做
然後分享給各位
分享給各位
最近這方法很好做
大家趕快來做
我們是用實戰
去跟各位講
什麼好做什麼不好做
就像那個小秘書跟我講
小哥最近要不要開一下放空實戰班
我說最近不要開
因为最近放空特难做
所以最近不要开放空时再办我们都会想说最近什么方法比较好做就教你什么方法那為什麼我知道什麼方法比較好做很簡單吧 因為我們很多策略很多策略
然後呢 這策略呢一定有比較賺錢的
有比較最近不好賺的
那我們就是
我們就是把比較好賺的跟你講
對不對 把比較好賺的跟你講
那比較不好做的 自己做不好做
我們就不會跟你講
最近這個策略不好做
所以呢 我們是用實戰呢 來過我們的每一天
好不好 跟各位講 我是用實戰過每一天
那實戰過每一天 我們就有很多交易心得嘛
然後又付了很多交易稅嘛
付了很多交易稅
所以呢 所以我這個 欸
我是覺得這種 這種實戰的心得呢
是最寶貴的 最寶貴的嘛
你看那個松山哥去
那個台大演講
坐無虛席 為什麼
因為大家都想去聽實戰嘛
想去聽實戰的東西
懂不懂
所以這種實戰的東西呢
這個其實我覺得
在市場裡面
市場裡面你要聽到實戰的東西
其實不大容易啊
為什麼 因為
很會講的
他可能不能做
分析師他講的很好聽啊
但是他不能做啊 他只能買ETF啊
對不對 他只能買ETF
你說他現股他都有在下嗎
他不一定有在下啊
應該說他本人是不能下的好不好
分析師本人是不能下現股的
然後他可能講的很好聽
那你也不曉得他有沒有真的做嘛
你懂我意思嗎
我假如是個分析師
假如是個分析師
那我就跟你
跟你講了這個
這個掌金版的股票
我是非議是說跟你講掌金版的股票
我跟你講七檔
你一定覺得我在唬爛你
對不對 你一定覺得我在唬爛我在騙你嘛
對不對 你真的有買嗎
這個真笑耶
你真的有買嗎
這七檔我有買五檔
我沒有每檔都買
七檔我買五檔
那為什麼我買這五檔
因為這五檔就是浪子回頭嘛
就浪子回頭 所以我們才買的啊
那買的理由都有
所以有很多人
他就跟我講說他裡面他也有
各位呢你只可以去看留言
這留言蠻多的
呵呵
最终什么三宝吧
运气好 实力更
中探针
来看一下
有跟到 就是有买嘛
每一档买得起
没有一档买得起
有抢到三档 有看到
有抢到三档就是 他有用主治神器
所以他就有抢到三档
来月城
月城这个买到
所以你自己看
所以你要想的是 為什麼人家也買得到
我也會選天象
這個月城沒有贏收 月城不用贏收
月城有1100的台積電啊
這根本不用贏收
再靠買股下去就夠了
月城小哥是不是出早了 出得有點早
我月城我出在第一根
因為他
我還以為他打開
可惜啦
好 所以呢
欸 這些都是我們教的方法
我們教各位這些方法
那就像我們在
我們在這個 教 我們在
我們也常常
常常在這邊啊 這邊全證小個交易比例
常在這裡
在這邊呢 看到的股票
也就是說 從這邊看到的這個波段全證
波段全證
那我們來看一下
最近的不斷權政有幾個也蠻猛的啦
不斷權政在後面
我們之前有講幾個不斷權政
例如說像那個
哎呦 漢堂最近衝了
得綠也不錯
然後呢 之前有講的不斷權政有像
像這裡啊
我記得有經濟嘛 這裡啊
經濟我們就說啊
這個有蒙金類虎呢
在疊下來之後他是大買
經濟
這邊大買
然後呢去理財達人秀也會講
這個大買
理財達人秀講了很多檔這個波段權政
那後面有的都有動
這些波段權政之前有講過
例如說像新勝利
新勝利有講 新勝利後面也噴的
還有像那個九元
九元之前有講在這裡
講完之後噴了 最近大買
這些都有講
所以你假如看PP的話呢
你又可以再提早個
看PP的話你可以提早個幾天看到看PP的話可以提早個幾天看到看PV的話你可以提早幾天看到
那李一條要去算
要去算這個
這個什麼
你要去算處置神器
你要去算處置的
什麼股票被處置
你可以看處置神器
你要看撥算權證的
你可以看交易筆記本
所以你這些呢 這幾個都是
你會比電視媒體還要更早看到
因為我們每天都在看啊
所以各位 我們現在
教各位的方法是
你跟我同時間看到該看的東西
我們是同時間看到該看的東西
那你看電視你會比較晚一點嘛 那是當然的啊
因為你看電視 你只要打開電視
躺在沙發上 什麼事都不用做
那就跟你講好的
那當然是他的資訊會稍微落後一點嘛
所以你假如想要資訊比較前面一點
你當然要靠自己研究啊
對不對 靠自己研究
那我們也會幫你研究啊
我們幫你研究就是
我們呢在把比較特別的寫在交易筆記本上
你可以去看交易筆記本
然後呢這個怎麼算會被處置
那處置呢
他有沒有低頭
這些呢我們都設計在處置神器上
那設計在處置神器上
他還會通知你
你上班的時候呢 你想做一件事
這個
把耳機塞在耳朵裡
把頭髮蓋起來
把處置神器打開
然後
然後把它手機翻面
或者是把那個
手機亮度調按
把手機亮度調按
它就通知你 讓紙回頭
某種股票讓紙回頭
通知你之後呢
你要買你就自己再想辦法買
就這樣而已啊
所以呢這些處置神器的策略
真的好用
我們來看一下 看一下學者留言啦
這邊有留言
怎麼樣
處置神器好用喔 這個勝率百分之百
小資主用全證
小資主你可以用全證投入啦
你也可以用那個
用全證投入你也可以用
用零股
那處置神器你覺得很貴喔
今天有活動喔
其實組織成績貴是因為
因為我們每個月都有陪跑那我們還會辦那個大型講座嗎其實是把這些含在裡面含裡面你也可以不要買OK 各位請有一對人會勸你不要買
好不好
很多買的人都勸你不要買
不要買 不要來搶這個利潤
不要搶這個利潤
這個很多人會勸你不要買
好啦 那這個主要是因為他有陪跑
我們陪跑到12月
陪跑到12月
然後呢
然後呢 它未來還會有這個網頁版
你看說現在就網頁版了 我們在 還在這個 還在
這個還在優化中
那除了網頁版以外呢
喔 除了網頁版以外呢 這個 未來呢 還有一個東西喔
等一下 多接著電話
喔 未來還會有一個東西 我是覺得最特別的啦
喔 這個跟各位講一下 未來有這個東西
這個目前這個市面上喔
目前市面上要去算一個東西很難算
再講一個東西
目前市面上呢
要算一個東西很難算
這個我跟各位講一下
就是說當你遇到第六款的話
那你假如遇到同族群本益比
同族群本益比
這個會很難算
但以後呢
處置神機他們已經優化到
他去盤中算同族群本益比
厲害了吧
盤中算同租金本益比
欸這個
這個一般人他沒辦法去
沒辦法盤中算啦
一般你在坊間看到的
都是前一天先算好嘛
那隔天去猜一看看
看能不能猜對
但是每次遇到第六款就很麻煩
就是你以為他會進
結果他沒進
很麻煩
那現在儲事成績
他們已經在優化到更優化
優化到更優化
那你覺得他好不好用
我覺得它非常好用啦
覺得它好不好用可以看一個東西喔
給各位看一下
從這邊可以看喔 這裡
你可以看這個相片啦 這邊有
貨貼
這邊喔
這個喔 這個是我們在台北辦的
處置股的實戰辦
那這個我們沒有
這個沒有對外開啦
對話開當然是更多人會來上
就沒有對話開
就是開放給那個VVIP的人就是有買也神奇的人會過來那事後呢我就簽名是那個 我們就開放一個簽名的地方上完課簽名
那簽名的時候我就問一下
欸 有賺到了 有沒有賺到
那大部分跟我回饋的都是有賺到
大部分跟我回饋的都是有賺到
他們都覺得有賺到
好啦
那你假如說一個策略不好用
我們把它設計成一個軟體
繼承一個軟體
然後呢
他們付費之後呢
他覺得不好用
你覺得他們是來幹嘛你知道嗎
他在尋醜的好不好
這些人來尋醜
你知道嗎
來尋醜
小哥賣我一個爛東西
你懂我意思嗎
你有看過那種
你有看過那種把
把一些那個用過的費用
然後再把它全部再召集起來
我們這個沒有跟他們再多收費
就是再召集起來
那一定是好用才敢召集嘛
你懂我意思嗎
不然你就下次去看一下那個
投稿老師喔 假如有個投稿老師
他去把他的所有會員召集起來
開個同樂會
我也蠻佩服的
我真的蠻佩服的
假如有投稿老師可以這樣幹
這一定是個優秀的投稿老師
一定是個優秀的投稿老師
他可以把他的所有會員召集起來
一般會員 普通會員在這裡
普通會員坐後面
總統會員坐前面
把所有會員叫來
他假如可以敢這麼做的話
我覺得也非常棒
真的好不好
那就很好
這個童吳老師一定要去參加
因為他很真實的去面對他的
他的那個
他的會員
那我是很真實的去面對這些學員
懂我意思嗎
真實面對這些學員
所以我們在上面講了很多美感
好不好
你想知道這些美感
那裡面講了很多美感
那給各位看一下我講了什麼美感
欸 我直接開給各位看啊
來
這邊啊
我開一下我的手機給你看
換對賬單啊
因為對賬單有人會認為說我對賬單是批的嘛
批的很簡單啦 你要讓人家覺得你不是批的很簡單
你就拿來滑一滑就好了
你把對賬拿來滑一滑
你就知道是不是批的了
來來來來
這邊這裡喔
很勇敢的齁
按查詢
查詢都跑出來了對不對
這可以滑的喔
可以滑的
就不是那個了吧
各位你看到有沒有
9點41分
這不是錄影的喔
我去錄一段影片
然後批個圖錄個影片
再把對方放下來
沒那麼厲害好不好
各位你看這41分41分
這41分這不是影片喔這是可以滑的
滑的喔各位可以看可以滑的喔
交易的下金我用這兩個月嘛這兩個月其實這個做處置做最多啦
有沒有看到
就7000啦這邊
就我們剛剛數字嘛對不對
好那這些呢
各位很多啦
超多
超多哈
然後這個
我們再看一個東西
我的
這裡啊
381有沒有看到
381才我賺多少
116萬
今天賣的116
這邊哦67萬
三四八一賺六七萬賺十萬嘛
好
那三四八一我是買在這邊的
三四八一買在這裡
買在這邊
一根兩根這根賣掉
買在這裡喔
那為什麼會買呢
為什麼想到會買呢
我有跟學員講
我跟學員講說我為什麼去買它
喔
那光這些know how
他就值多少錢
七十幾萬嘛
就值七十幾萬了
這know how 他其實一個很簡單的一個邏輯而已
他就是一個非常簡單的邏輯
好不好 很簡單的邏輯
結果你看今天
這個群賞誰買
今天群賞是國泰頓來買賠了6000萬
但大黑K都有他啦
大黑K都有他
我們買在這裡
我今天是賣在開盤價
今天開盤我就掛平盤出
我今天開盤就掛平盤出因為我知道它會開高啊我就掛平盤出沒差我今天賣在52塊
我是今天賣52
那這邊他會顯示51.8
因為他扣掉一些成本
我這邊扣到51
我這邊算51.8
扣掉一些成本
那為什麼國外都要來買這麼多
國外都要來每次都這樣嘛
這個賺錢做當充嘛
賠錢做股東嘛
國外都男人常都這樣
再講一次喔
賺錢做當衝
賠錢做股東
賺錢呢 當衝
賺錢當衝嘛
賠錢就怎麼樣
做存股
我要存股
群創沒問題的啦
存股
那他會不會解套呢
他常常在解套
所以國外都男人這些會不會解套
他是有機會解套的
因為
前創還在一個多頭的走勢嘛 所以他有機會解套
但是呢 他會有一次沒辦法解套
會有一次沒辦法解套 只是那一次呢
他就會賠很慘了 那次他會套很久
所以每一檔股票呢 高檔都有國泰蹲難
這講一次喔 每一檔股票的高檔都有國泰蹲難
都有國泰蹲難
好 那所以這個 跟各位講 我們用這個
呃
組織來做交易
它有一些美感
你要怎麼看 怎麼買
訊號怎麼通知
訊號怎麼通知你
通知你之後你該做什麼事
所以重點是
你看到了這個浪子回頭
你該怎麼辦
我在禮拜天的課呢
就講得很清楚
例如說你在5月20號
你會看到很多浪子回頭
因為5月20號那天大盤最弱
大盤那天跌破了月線
5月20號那天我是做什麼事情
5月20號那天我不是把股票全部砍掉
我股票全部砍掉
我就沒有這一段了好不好
這個其實5月25號
20號以後賺更多
再講一次喔
5月20號以後賺更多
你看一下
我有一堆錢
哇 都是21號賺的
這裡齁 來 看一下 這裡
這裡齁
我有一堆都是21號以後賺的 賺了2800萬一堆啊都21號以後賺那在這天我們要做什麼事呢
在這天呢 我們要
做換股
再講一次喔
這一天呢 我們要做換股
就是呢
要把一些股票換掉
為什麼 因為你在這天你可能會接到手軟嘛
所以呢 你必須要做點換股
那你只好有做換股的話
你心裡面比較舒服
好不好
你心裡面比較舒服 你至少還抱得住
你假如沒做換股 在這邊全部停損
這一天有人全部停損啊
為什麼 破月線全部停損 全面停損
也不能說他錯啦 他搞不好有一次是對的
但是呢 在我們的做處置的股票裡面
破月線它大部分是個買點
它通常不會停損
所以呢 你假如在這裡
在這裡它是個空頭股票破業線
我覺得本來就在停損
但在儲置股裡面破業線
它反而是個大買點
所以我在這邊買了一堆
那我就在這四天呢
就大獲全勝
你看這四天呢
就賺了兩千八
也有很大的原因是因為
這四天一堆股票大漲嘛
那當然是我們這四天的獲利就比較豐厚嘛
那這些方法
都有
教各位
不管是在處置裡面的課程
在處置神器裡面的這個實體課程
我們是處置一個神器裡面它有影音課程
有實體課程
還有每個月的陪跑
所以各位你加一加你是得到非常多個小時的教學
所以你說它貴呢
事實上它有很多個小時教學
還有寶貴的經驗
那重點我們交了很多交易稅嘛
交很多交易稅你覺得這個費用很貴
這個費用呢大概
欸
各位今天買的大概不夠
不過我一個月的交易稅
所以呢
你買一買
你買的錢大概可能也是給政府了
變成交易稅去了
所以這個
這些
交易稅都是豐富的經驗
那這些豐富的經驗呢
我們會持續的去優化這個軟體
我們要打造這個全台算最準的一個處置神器
我們為什麼可以有這個信心呢
就是我們現在可以盤中即時算
盤中即時算
其實要盤中即時算了
是有點困難的
有點困難那什麼叫PayPal呢PayPal是這樣子我們每個月都會錄一段影片每個月錄一段影片來跟各位分享一下我這個月做得怎麼樣啊
那這個月
我們看一下這個月的
處置的股票長怎麼樣啊
那你把每一檔處置股票看一遍
然後再回答一下這個月
學員的問題
學員的問題一堆啊
回答一下學員的問題
那
那你回答這些問題
其實要花滿多時間了
花很多時間去做這些啊
那你會買完之後
你會欸 小哥陪著我做這個交易
那我們就可以看小哥最近做得順不順
那一直以來
我們大概在5月19、20號那兩天是滿不順的啦
因為那兩天很多儲置股都大跌
滿不順的
那但是在不順的時候
我們有不順的做法嘛
不順的時候呢 我們就換股
我們把那個跌得沒那麼慘的
換成跌就更慘的
那因為你這個換股之後呢
這個因為跌更慘的反彈更兇嘛
所以你就是你再去挑一些股票
更審慎的挑啦
在那幾天你要謹慎的挑
在這幾天你想挑都沒得挑
好不好
你現在大盤連漲了
連漲了快4000點
你想挑都沒得挑
你現在想挑什麼有下跌的股票
很少了
所以最近想挑沒得挑
我最近呢是蠻期待他再回一次月線
再回一次月線
那麼呢就會出現什麼
就會出現一堆被動元件的買點
再講一次喔
這個
再回一次月線
我這句話已經講太多次了
每次都很準喔
各位你去回憶一下
我講說
經濟
我們上次直播的時候就講
經濟呢
處置只要有回檔
就會出現一個超級好的買點
對不對 是不是有講過
那更早之前呢有講
旺虹只要有處置回檔
就會出現一個超級無敵好的買點
我有買到1.5
那經濟呢 我有買到130幾
130幾的經濟
後面又說聯發科
好不好 聯發科
聯發科喔
处置会出现一个非常好的买碟
那时候就跟各位讲了
我们就希望联发哥被关嘛
主动他被关 好不好
那我先跟各位讲
现在呢 有一堆
有一堆什麼股票被關了
有一堆被動元件被關了
那這波呢
被動是不是最後一波我不知道
但是呢 常常電子股呢
這個走到後面呢 都是被動元件
這個電子股走到最後都被動元件
那被動元件呢
最近齁 他會休息
再跟各位講
最近被動元件會休息
資金呢會跑到別的地方去
那為什麼最近被動元件會休息呢
各位看一下齁
好 今天的強勢類股裡面
各位看一下
今天強勢類股裡面
被動元件呢
顯然的就比較少一點
你假如前幾天看 全部都被動元件
兩天前看啊
這裡啊
我們歷史模式給你看
歷史
這個5月25號
5月25號
丈夫
5月20號漲停板
5月20號漲停板這裡
喔這漲停板太多了
太多了我們看一下
我把它塞一下好了
因為這...這在太多了
這邊
細產業包含被動
好
好 各位看一下
這個
昨天 欸 昨天的漲停板啊
排序一下
昨天被動漲停板大概幾隻啊
大概有十幾隻
昨天有十幾隻
好 然後呢 各位你再看一下前一天
5月22號
5月20號 哇塞被動了十幾隻欸 有沒有
這個5月21號 漲停板
十幾隻 有沒有
最後十幾隻啊
然後今天 今天被動元件的漲停板
喔
這重疊了
今天被動元件漲停板變很少了
那他重疊到了
哎呀等一下因為他讀了兩次數據重點這裡
好啦 今天被動元件漲停剩幾支 剩五支
對不對 那明天呢 可能又會再更弱一點
明天被動元件呢 可能又再更弱啊
就不會那麼多支了
所以呢 資金呢 會開始
流到別的地方去
资金会流到别的地方去
可能流到记忆体啊
可能流到
可能流到这个重电嘛
重电
可能流到这些地方去
那被动元件呢
就会有比较像样的跌幅
可能未来两三天啦
被动元件可能有比较像样的
就是大部分下跌这样子
那今天被动元件呢
已经有一些开始跌了
爱华 密忘石 复制 这边
連國劇都跌4%
今天有一些比較弱
有被動元件比較弱
那這些比較弱的狀況呢
可能會持續個兩三天
可能啊 我不確定
可能會持續兩三天
那資金呢 就離到別的地方去
所以呢 未來被動元件
在何時會出現好的買點呢
各位呢
你一定要耗著關注這個軟體
這個軟體呢 叫做
各位
你一定要耗著關注這個軟體
處置神器
這樣
他會通知你
好不好他會通知你
你在這邊按一下
這邊通知你
浪子回頭
那
像生意留言不用看了啦
浪子回頭各位看
浪子回頭
這個
一殺就往下
一殺就往上拉了
那我覺得光潔最好再殺一下
再殺一下會比較漂亮
那今天他一出現訊號就往上升了
所以這邊呢
這個之後呢會有浪子回頭的訊號
會通知你在被動元件
所以呢我可以跟各位預言
我下一波賺很大的股票
可能就在被動元件了
我呢被動元件呢會找一個好的買點
會找一個好的買點買進
就像最近聯發哥有賺到嗎
有賺到嗎
那各位呢 你看到我那對賬單
那對賬單裡面
有些處置的我們不是買在這個戶頭我們是買在自己的戶頭買在自己的戶頭那這個未來未來我覺得應該在下個禮拜
下個禮拜我們就有機會給各位看
下禮拜或是下下禮拜
有機會給各位看那個
被動元件的
這個獲利狀況
因為被動元件
它是大規模的背關
大規模背關呢
現在背關的股票太多被動元件
太多了
被動元件呢 太多被關了
喔
來 我們看這個
處置坐牢中 這裡啊
你看一下
欸
跑掉了
我把它按掉了 等我一下
好
欸 欸
好 現在被動元件的股票太多被關了
這裡 有沒有看到
這裡太多被關了
然後呢
各位啊
明天你可以注意到什麼股票
明天呢你可以看一下
它有今天出關股票 這是明天要出關的
各位 這是明天要出關的
晚上寫起來 今天出關 它是明天要出關的
所以明天有中右 川湖 聯軍 建策
監測 安睿 华星光 這些
明天要出關的
然後被動呢 他今天被關的 這裡有
處置座牢中
這邊有這個
剛剛被關的 我們找一下剩餘的天數
剩餘天數
你看 今天有剛被關的
华興科
日電帽 日電帽是從5分鐘變20分鐘
哦 花心科 日電貿國巨大義和聲堂
你看這邊有一堆被動元件
哦 所以呢 這些被動元件實在太多了
所以導致他怎麼樣
導致他未來的走勢呢 可能就沒辦法這麼好
沒辦法這麼整齊了嘛 因為太多被關了
所以未來的資金呢 會先跑到別的地方去
那這些呢 都是 呃 各位你可以
下禮拜你可以好好關注的
好 關注的
好啦
所以這處置神器很好用啦
非常好用
買處置神器首期會加45000
然後它會有進階軟體一年期權限進階線上課程全攻略它有線上課程然後它會有實體課程的影音因為實體課程我們上網來
所以有實體課程的影音
然後第二年期它有個續定價
然後裡面有基礎處置策略
進階處置策略 雙刀戰法 每月十戰賠跑
策略更新加復盤到2020年底
專屬討論群組 目前有1000多 1000出頭人
喔一千出頭來的齁
那這個限時活動只到5月27號
5月27號
所以各位要加的話呢
就到5月27號啦
喔那這儲資神器喔
那各位你看一下
這個是選的獲利狀況
華星光日電貿
欸這些都是被動元件的股票
一全啊這幾個
喔儲資神器真的好像用太弱留強
感恩市長感恩小哥感恩神器
這種旁邊還能如此獲利
喔各位群友荷包滿滿
你看這邊都有
每天都賺錢收工
感謝我感謝廚師神奇
這裡
這是學員的心得
買廚師軟體田已經回本了
就算你有一天是我一輩子
我也很支出 繼續努力
我也要上期
我未來給我賺錢
充滿可以是跟你買的
用三年了
自從使用後考試都考一本
哈哈哈哈
別是上個月開始訂
這邊啊
這邊都是學員他的心得
那這
我們這些都是
反正是學員
呃
他買軟體就加群嘛
上課也加群
那加群讓他們自己聊
我們通常不大會限制
那這種聊的就實際的真實的心得狀況
我們在裡面也不會準備一些拖啊
然後在那邊感恩老師讚嘆老師都沒有
因為我平常我就很不常在那邊聊天嘛
不常在那邊聊天就沒有什麼感恩老師讚嘆老師這種東西啦
好 這感謝儲持人機這裡齁
這個...來看一下
所以儲持人機充滿好標題
這大盤好勝率是很高的
儲持人機充滿好標題真的是很高啦
有這麼幸福嗎 儲持人機四顆燈啦
四顆燈 這賺很多
好啦 所以儲值神技很好用喔
儲值神技可以幫助你
儲值日報 明日準確度高到99%
然後呢 可以監控
監控股票
然後獨家統計功能
那這統計喔 這統計我是覺得
我們這統計我們已經看了很多
很多次了
那這統計呢 就長這樣子
給各位看一下 最新的統計狀況
最新的統計狀況是長這樣
這全樣本呢 就是第一天比較弱
後面都比較強
然後呢 5分鐘來看呢
是前三天比較弱 後面比較強
那20分鐘呢 第一天比較弱 後面都很強
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕